a new lawsuit is expected this week
against a California fertility clinic
that admits it may have accidentally
destroyed thousands of frozen embryos
and at least one more lawsuit has been
filed against University Hospitals a
huija Medical Center near Cleveland an
equipment malfunction there may have
damaged thousands of eggs or embryos to
find out how these types of labs operate
CBS this morning went inside a different
fertility clinic in California dr. Tara
Narula is here with what we learned Tara
good morning good morning Nora
maintaining these embryos and eggs is
difficult but there are several
procedures in place that will notify
doctors if and when something goes wrong
we decided to visit a fertility clinic
in Santa Barbara to see how this process
works and what can possibly be done to
prevent devastating incidents like those
we've seen so these are our liquid
nitrogen tanks where we maintain the
embryos and eggs dr. Rene Allen took us
through his lab at the Santa Barbara
fertility Center to show us how the
clinic keeps its eggs and embryos safe
there's a sensor here that's inside the
liquid nitrogen so if the levels were to
drop too low maybe to about here
it would then send an alert that alert
would immediately set off this alarm if
no one is at the lab to answer it a
second alert is sent to several doctors
cell phones as you can see it's at a
adequate level here his clinic even
maintains backup tanks one of many
safeguards to protect the delicate
embryos there's six of these within the
tank and while each clinic is different
news of the failure of the tanks at two
other facilities on the same day in
California and Ohio has rattled the
fertility industry it's a real shock
Katie Miller has been a patient with
Pacific fertility center since 2009 she
is one of about five hundred people who
received a letter saying that a March
4th malfunction may have affected her
embryos I think if the child is reading
it now there really are so many
questions at this point and you know
hopefully there will be some good news
I'm but at the same time I know there
have to be people who've already
received probably very devastating news
this is a tragic loss for anybody
attorney Adam Wolfe tells CBS News he
plans to file a class-action lawsuit
against the Sanford
Disko clinic this week on behalf of the
patients he also filed a second lawsuit
against the Ahuja medical center outside
Cleveland what the past week has shown
us is that there needs to be greater
regulation there needs to be some more
controls so that something like this
never happens again dr. Allen did tell
us that he must have licenses from the
FDA for tissue donation and for handling
embryos and eggs but he also told us
there is no outside regulation on the
tanks themselves leaving doctors to
maintain the safety precautions on their
own both affected fertility clinics did
not offer new statements but they told
us they are investigating the incidents
hmmm so upsetting the whole thing yeah
every time I think about it and think
about the women that are now thinking
that this was could have been their only
hope it's very very devastating exactly
it's such an investment emotionally
physically financially early is thank
you Tara